Qué tipo de crímenes se han registrado
contra periodistas durante el último año
y qué se sabe sobre la cifra de
impunidad
bueno los crímenes que han prevalecido
en América Latina en algunos países en
particular son los asesinatos pero
también tenemos una amplia fragilidad de
vulnerabilidad de la prensa en América
Latina particular en países
particularmente en países como Brasil
Honduras Colombia Venezuela por
mencionar algunos estos son los países
que digamos representan una mayor
vulnerabilidad para la prensa pero
también hay otras series de dificultades
como son la desconfianza hacia la prensa
se ha acelerado de manera constante
acompañado de un discurso estigmatizante
por parte de políticos Pues que se
sienten exhibidos por la información que
la que los medios difunden ahora qué
factores están contribuyendo a que haya
impunidad en estos casos
los principales factores que influyen
para que haya impunidad es la nueva
actuación en las investigaciones en la
detención de los autores materiales
intelectuales de las agresiones a
periodistas a nivel general y en
particular en México Pues en los
asesinatos donde este año tenemos
14 periodistas asesinados Qué acciones
por ejemplo demandan desde reporteros
Sin fronteras para que finalice o para
que termine la impunidad en los
asesinatos contra periodistas
Bueno una de las acciones principales
que hemos difundido el día de hoy es
este compromiso de Fiscales de ocho
Fiscales a nivel internacional para que
puedan
difundir este compromiso
de actuar de manera pronta y expedita en
las investigaciones